you had that much power on set they'll
be like do what he says you know
everyone is pretty like the writer's
room is pretty open to like what you
like the suggestions that you have
that's dope it was cool that they were
like oh yeah that might be cool is that
why the show got canceled yeah probably
because they listen to you
[Music]
I'm using episode of lost careful boyos
today we have I am Lawrence Cal in the
building hi
[Applause]
I like this Duo the legend himself we
are sponsored by oatmeal Lawrence is a
duel no you too you this two Duo man you
like that it's pretty good yeah this is
the thumbnail every time we brought them
along on a on a JK skit we always talk
about this like this so so yeah we
shouldn't even talk about it anymore
because we always had them do gay stuff
whoa whoa whoa oh I thought that you
just let them I thought you just let
them uh improv it oh true yeah yeah
they insist you just made a strong
Choice it was never about gay stuff it
was about having some pizza have some
pizza that's the only way we thought we
were funny if we were gay
that was like that was in our toolbox
it's like [__] what are they gonna laugh
at let's just we were like we were like
jokes out and then nobody wait no one's
laughing yeah we touch each other and
then me and Bart was like these guys are
so comfortable like whenever we need
like guys to just be gay let's just keep
getting them to do the gay stuff a nice
little JK Typecast
but you guys did it to yourselves yeah
it worked out really well yeah yeah and
look we're still here yeah still made it
but you don't have to be you don't have
to be gay no more you can be yourself
yeah you can stop now yeah you can stop
when we get nervous and then we're just
like what do we do
we run out of jokes it's it's often
though just just make out already
they're not laughing anymore so uh touch
me here we need the views you know it
would be crazy views if you guys made
out of it it's important or cooler stuff
though okay okay um hey you just came
back from London you just came back from
you sound like you're from London what
were you doing for a lot of dance Sarah
Marshall baby
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah who said that one
Russell Brad no it's the other guy so
Paul Rudd when he's talking to uh yeah
from London yeah
what did you what did you do there
slightly jet-like a little bit or not
really I'm like energetic now but I
might just die like in a couple hours
wind crash when did you when did you
come back last night at 10 oh last night
I made the mistake of sleeping the whole
ride back oh oh what time did you sleep
last night
I tried to sleep at 11. oh [__] well but
I'm here hell of a sunrise though thanks
for being here dude got some coffee yeah
you'll be fine sorry sorry sorry [__]
how do you drink it during this thing
man yo you gotta go like this
and then you go yeah there you go Ken
Ken's gonna put a June B logo on
everything yeah you could put it in a
jumby cup if you would like oh do you
have a jumpy cup yeah it's gonna taste
weird after you do that but I'm not
gonna get it we're gonna get it the next
episode you just came back from London I
came back from London what were you
doing in London uh my girlfriend lives
in London so we're doing like a little
long distance
did you meet her there yeah that's like
my story you you Thief yeah I'm trying
to be like you Joe yeah you both have
girls from London well she's not from
London you met her there uh I met her
working actually oh cool yeah and um
no it was in in Walker Oh I was gonna
say was it Glenn's girlfriend because
she's London in me right is she lemonade
I don't know if she's lending me like
Australia yeah the girl on Walking Dead
that was the girlfriend of uh Glenn no
it's not walking dead it's Walker
tall different different show
he does a lot of walking stuff yeah yeah
Walking Dead Walking Around walk around
so you're you're all Walker Texas Ranger
no uh yeah it's like a it's like a
prequel to that it's outside so what is
it like
Chuck Norris it's like uh it the old one
was Chuck Norris this one isn't Chuck
Norris and this one this one the prequel
one from that is really not Chuck Norris
it's just like I think it was an excuse
for them to make like a a like a like a
western they're like oh how can we make
a western and then Walker Independence
Independence yeah what what network was
on it was on CW c-dubs so just keep
relaying so you're uh just want to make
sure he's the middleman he's my
translator I'm caught up
okay this is a fascinating life because
it mirrors mine yeah yeah how did you
guys meet I'll tell you later it's about
you right now hey you know why you would
like his character why because for for
some of the series he has like an Asian
accent but it's fake
and then it's like [__] what am I gonna
do now how am I gonna do it so it's like
because you're doing it so fake yeah I'm
trying where I'm trying to do it so that
people aren't laughing at it
China that's not gonna work you know
that's that's the Jeremy Lin doing math
yeah that's Jeremy Lin doing math is not
good for the show
every time you do that voice I'm like
dude that's Jeremy Lim that's fisherman
bro yeah if someone watched Walker and
was like wait a minute is this guy from
Superior
he's so sick of the director was like
hold on what that reminds you of
something hold on don't tell me don't
tell me oh we gotta recast we gotta
recast yeah or he just hear someone said
he's like no I need it more like this
video as a reference this is the perfect
tone we're looking for so so you you had
the difficult task of sexualizing the
Chinese accents yeah I guess so I guess
so how you sexualize it try to make it
more like gay Soulful I guess so what's
the difference with like because you
know when you're doing a Chinese accent
versus you're doing it as a character
who's trying to hide that it's not real
that's the Nuance of it right I thought
that was interesting because his
character's faking it and it's not
that's so funny scary's faking it to
hide it's like he's like doesn't really
talk like that so and it's not funny
that's so hard it is it is really hard
but
put it on right now it's hard because
we're on just kidding uh news
but you know it was actually like sort
of my idea to make it so he had the
backstory that he was faking it because
in the beginning of the show like that
wasn't in the script so I chatted you
had that much power on set they'll be
like do what he says no everyone is
pretty like the writer's room is pretty
open to like what you like the
suggestions that you have that's dope it
was cool that they were like oh yeah
that might be cool is that why the show
got canceled yeah probably because they
listen to you yeah it was me because
everyone watching was like oh
we got
you guys the director's all man I love
this show but we just had to listen to
Lawrence
so you're
so your lady you met in the Showbiz
um yeah we met working on another
another thing and then we kept in
contact and is she famous she is uh
famous she's just starting out but she's
really good is she an actor like
yourself yes how's the long distance
it's pretty hard time zones time zone is
pretty tough but I think that if like
both people are busy and they're just
staying busy doing stuff like it's okay
like you know there's that's true
distance is actually a little nice how
often do you see her we see each other
like maybe every three two to three
months okay so she's probably gonna come
back she's gonna come here like in
November am I gonna I'm gonna go there
probably in January do you think this
kind of like stuff like content is there
a cup of tea her cup of tea oh she likes
she likes chicken news oh she does okay
so she watched it beforehand we'll be
less censored then then once when she's
visiting you you guys should come
together and talk about it yeah we
should pretend to be like siamese twins
oh yeah and put on one shirt like put on
a character you know like hey do they
they don't talk like that
is she fake Chinese too she's uh does
she please save Chinese rolls she's half
Thai half uh English oh cool I'll tell
you so she could play fake Chinese she
could play fake Chinese yeah does she
have a better fake Chinese accent than
you what do you think um I don't know we
should uh test it out
what was like the when the chemistry
developed was that like on screen
chemistry that was developing or was it
like
backstage in the trailers
um we just we just definitely had a
connection like on screen and off screen
too like and then just kept talking and
then like you know spilled from there
was it like written in your guys's roles
uh before you guys have certain
chemistry like yeah like those things
developed yeah we were loving it we were
loved interests oh okay but it doesn't
necessarily
like that it's written in the stars or
like things are sparked because like you
all have love interests with people
doing stuff and then it'll just be like
man she's
she's an attractive girl but it's like
nothing you just oh yeah it's just it's
just like I hate her I want to kill her
God damn I can't wait for this to be
done no yeah so like even if it's
written in you so it's like yeah it's
like
you have to believe it in the moment but
out outside of it you know it's not
always like
like damn like you're into that person
yeah did you feel like Angelina Jolie on
on Mr Mrs Smith that's all I was
thinking about too you just like that's
it yeah like he's my man I guess so do
you guys have any on-screen makeout uh
yeah we did and then were you practicing
a lot is this from like the you guys did
like a movie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you practice I know which one he is
now
that's I wish you guys did I wish you
guys did showing up to the RV like hey
we gotta rehearse for these scenes you
don't even want to make sure that's
convincing because you both really like
each other other you just keep going and
you're like oh and you're like I think
we got to do that again yeah that part
we messed up let's take it from the top
be as creepy as possible yeah
like five times it's like we called cut
like 20 minutes ago guys I think we need
to do that again I just didn't I feel
like I could do better yeah yeah
sometimes the directors are weird too
where they don't even like tell they
like it's not even written in the script
to kiss and then they'll pull you aside
and they'll be like hey you know like
why don't you like why don't you kiss
him in this thing yeah why don't you
grab his ass a little bit what's the
matter you gay
well you don't like her I don't think
that's a good thing how about we just
get a new girl there's been times where
it's like that's happened like it's come
like all of a sudden yeah that's
happened to you so it's like a A in the
spur of the moment non-consensual kiss
directed by the director yes
specifically with the director not
letting the other person know so that
yeah I feel like yes yes I think that's
a tricky thing to do because you never
know like the chemistry between the two
people I mean obviously if like the
chemistry is strong it'd be easier for
the director to be like okay yeah go do
that don't let them so don't let them
right but it's a tricky like yeah
something something similar happened to
me on the set of Papa Roach Scars where
they asked these two girls to make out
and then they started laughing because
they knew it wasn't even in the shot
damn oh that's fine oh that's right you
mentioned that that's a Papa Roach shoot
though you know they they do things
differently in terms of high-fiving the
director and the Gaffers yeah they're
loving it the red light's not even on on
the camera so messed up just phones just
phones when would you say no though
because that's like weird yeah it's hard
to say like they have they have like so
much power too I mean I did I did this
like this little web series a long time
ago where the director pulled me aside
and it was a written I I played a gay
character and I was supposed to
it was on JK film and and uh the
director pulled me aside and he was like
dude I think a kiss would be good for
the scene sounds like Barney can you
just do it and like you're a man right
you're a man right you're a man so you
could do man oh he was like trying to
pump you up like that yeah and I was
like okay sure yeah let's do it let's go
and the other character was Dante Bosco
was it hey that's a that's a good first
kiss dude yeah that's a good kiss that's
just paying it back right don't take a
good lips you were like questioning it
like this we're filming Noah's Ark like
why are we
[Laughter]
you're like I don't think this is in the
story and they're like oh I know but
we're trying to make it modern you know
like we want to make it modern and who
was Noah [__] on the yard come on you
know and then like he had options yeah
but we don't want to go to animals so
yeah it's a little too hardcore it's
like how do you oh it's because I played
an animal
[Laughter]
where can we go see Lawrence kiss oh
you're not gonna find it uh come on
it's like this porno I did a long time
ago
it's a web series
back then those lived on specific sites
right the director didn't want you to
kiss the other gay guy in the porno
until at the very scene pulls them all
to the side hey I think
can you can you imagine being in a gay
porn and then you have to be talked into
kissing the guy and you're like
dang where all the gay porns I watch
dude they don't do any kissing they're
just flipping through pages it's not in
the description
the continuity is gonna be off
nudie yeah that's what that's a film
term Colleen you should know this yeah
important all right guys
make sure they got everything set up
what if like a porn actor had like a
double for his dick a dick double yeah
and it's a straight guy yeah like some
just like money making straight porno
dude but then like he never did the
[__] was that was that a rumor was
that a real thing with Willem Dafoe and
Antichrist oh yeah that's that's a
double
because apparently I thought it was his
dick was too big oh yeah yeah yeah they
had to use another one why didn't they
just use a [__] big ass dick what was
he doing it what was it it's a double
for um in that guy's other movie when
Shia LaBeouf
for um you seen that for nymphomaniac
same director Lars von Trier uh-huh they
you it looks like Shia LaBeouf straight
up yeah but it's a double no but isn't
aren't there full body scenes of him but
that's still uh they they uh graphed the
scene together so it's like who's the
direction has a different guy oh really
yeah it's like advanced technology at
that time yeah at the time I just I just
thought shot of the Buffalo just down
like that I mean I feel like he is but
maybe his agent was like don't do it
don't show your dick come on protect him
I'm going down like that yeah
you did holes you're already doing so
much out there this is gonna ruin your
Transformers career I'm not gonna be
able to sell you next season
is Agent who is this person does your
agent talk like that do you like your
agent um you should be my agent yeah I
would love to be right here if you get
up somebody he'll do it anything say no
more he's down say less say less he's
gonna do it have you had the same
manager or agent for the last like
forever yeah I've never switched wow
that's cool man it's a little bit um
well they're killing it they're doing a
good job
I mean a lot of people a lot of people
do tell me to switch out I just feel
like it's so hard like they've been with
me for so long loyalty yeah yeah the
King's Way they've watched like yeah
they've been with me since the beginning
so it's like it's hard to just be like
laters yeah I mean they're they seem
like they're doing good but they're from
an actual agency they're not right now
and end it yeah and it all counts me
it's not like there's someone's aunt or
something right they're an actual agent
from a agent agency so it's like why
switch everybody's wearing my best
friend
she's like family she might be an aunt
you know but like is it like Jerry
Maguire level is it like or is it like a
big agency no it's just it's a it's like
a smaller Boutique agency and my manager
that's been with me forever and then but
are there like like I could definitely
leave and go for a bigger Agency for
sure but it's like I I don't know I
don't want to nice everybody's telling
me we should though yeah is everyone
telling you should though yeah is your
agent telling you you should yeah even
my agent's like you gotta leave
here
don't do it already just do it spread
your wings you gotta fly
that's Ryan dude you guys have Jewish
lady ages all of you guys are Jewish
lady agents it's all about ants I think
that's the theme of the day I think the
best kind of agent I think I think yeah
I think both of my Asians
both your agents are Jewish ladies yeah
really oh they really are Pam and Gabby
holy [__] we're at duo we work together
we we do all the deals together
I'm Pam you're Gabby dude
all right go talk about my deal
so we're gonna do this movie it's called
Walker it's gonna be on the CW have you
heard of the CW before
and then what about you Pam what do you
got to say I thought you were bad
Gabby what are you gonna say Gabby I
hope they never [__] client said is
he's not gonna do it unless he can speak
Chinese
[Laughter]
for at least six episodes or we're out
that's very good and that's it what
about you you got one you got one dude
damn it Gabby there's no third Persona
you can be my manager yeah manager gay
black dude okay perfect well why does he
talk like this
laughs
he's just bad that's the [__] agency
and your manager his Showbiz baby
just how we talk it's Showbiz vernacular
you gotta talk like this to get the
deals yeah
that's good I think that's just Joy
Behar dude hey it is Joy Behar from The
View you watch The View no I don't okay
can't really trust Colleen's opinions
anymore
every good opinion comes from
honestly I feel like
Jewish lady that speaks like that though
every single have you stumbled across it
yeah dude I'm pretty sure they have to
yeah right it's by law can you send this
video to your agents yeah well maybe
they'll just ask me yeah they'll fire
you yeah they'll fire me just so you can
spread your wings honey
why you gotta try new things baby birds
gotta leave the nest someday
I'm so good